okay a Donald Trump's Attorney General
William bar testified under oath
yesterday before a House Appropriations
Subcommittee and Bendixon Feld and
filled in for me yesterday and he
already told you about sort of a lot of
the initial stuff that came from that
hearing and when William Barr was asked
the seemingly simple question of has the
White House seen the Muller report
already bar contorted himself into a
pretzel I mean it was like a circus
contortionist to avoid giving a direct
answer just so we're all on the same
page up to speed on what Ben talked
about yesterday listen to bars answer to
what seemed like a simple yes-or-no
question how see the report before you
released your summarizing letter has the
White House seen it since then have they
been briefed on the contents beyond what
was in you a summarizing letter to the
Judiciary Committee I've said what I'm
gonna say about the report today I've
issued three letters about it and I was
willing to discuss the historic
information of how the report came to me
in my decision on Sunday but I've
already laid out the process that is
going forward to release these reports
hopefully within a week and I'm not
gonna say anything more about it until
the report is out everyone has a chance
to look at it so until the report is out
he won't tell us anything about it
including even whether the White House
has seen the report which to me is a yes
okay I don't know any other way around
it has the White House seen the report
I'm not talking about the report right
now okay so the White House has seen it
is how I'm interpreting that but now we
have sort of like the real breaking news
which happened after yesterday's show
was filmed to add on to what Ben told us
yesterday which is that Attorney General
William bar is straight up refusing to
provide the unredacted report to
Congress there were questions as to who
would get which version when but
Congress
surely get a version that is not
redacted for anything beyond just the
absolute legally necessary redactions
and yet
no William bar is insisting that things
have to be redacted related to ongoing
investigations that's a maybe depending
on the clearance you could argue about
this but based on the clearance that
House Appropriations and House members
in general have you could probably
legally give them unredacted information
about ongoing investigations maybe you
couldn't maybe that one's legitimate
number two things have to be redacted in
the version the house will get this is
according to William bar for privacy
purposes this is basically bogus okay
when you're talking unless you're
linking the privacy to something some
kind of legal imperative privacy is not
a good reason for redactions in what's
going to ultimately go to the House of
Representatives and then thirdly and
this is where it just goes completely
off the rail for reputational purposes
redactions have to be made in the
version of the Moller report that
William bar plans to eventually send to
the House of Representatives this is the
boat most sort of disturbing thing about
this any sensible person understands
that some things have to be redacted and
the sort of highest standard would be
for legal reasons there are things that
must be redacted okay
that's very few things as I've pointed
out redaction of a version that goes to
Congress to preserve people's so-called
reputations is absolutely ludicrous
laughable and pathetic and what we may
get to here is that Congress has no
choice but to subpoena the unredacted
version more than likely Trump would
have his lawyers respond claiming
executive privilege and it would be a
question as to whether that makes any
sense but it could ultimately get to the
Supreme Court to skip ahead a few months
or years which of course Donald Trump
effectively has taken control of the
manipulations that date all the way back
to Mitch McConnell blocking Merrick
Garland's nomination
Barack Obama and once again Donald Trump
and his cronies desperate to hide the
details of a report that supposedly
totally clears him summarizing an
investigation that supposedly completely
exonerates him and it's really important
to remember that nothing that is
happening here is neither surprising nor
out of the plan that William bar was
hired to execute we said this when
William Barr was selected we said this
in fact before we knew William Barr was
going to be Donald Trump's election when
Matthew Whitaker was installed as the
temporary acting interim whatever the
title that was assigned to him was
Attorney General we knew at that point
and I said this is a stopgap carefully
calculated to allow someone to
temporarily hold the position that
probably wouldn't be able to get
confirmed for it because again Matthew
Whitaker had no business being Attorney
General who can sort of hold off and
minimally interfere with the Moller
probe until such time that Donald Trump
finds the right person in terms of what
he wants to accomplish and is able to
get that person confirmed and that is
exactly what had happened
William Barr was brought in to muddy up
the entire mulher probe and the report
he has done it with this four page
political we can't call it a summary
it's really a press release I think is
the most accurate term that he put out
several Sundays ago which barely even
quotes from Robert Muller's actual
report except to clarify that Robert
Muller was not able to exonerate Donald
Trump from obstruction of charges of
obstruction of justice charges and then
that is used by Donald Trump and his
friends to go on a nationwide
exoneration party tour and now that
we're actually getting closer to seeing
the report we being the public also we
being the House and Senate we don't know
exactly who will get which version and
when William bar gets in to deliberately
gum this thing up as much as possible
and it would be normal people would see
a year delay or even a six-month delay
or whatever as this works its way
through the legal system as a
huge fail failure as a failure to keep
the public and our elected officials and
faut informed about what it is that our
executive branch the White House is
doing this is a victory okay if they can
successfully gum this up get some bogus
outrageously redacted version of the
report sent to Congress which Congress
then has to complain about and they can
say Congress and Democrats in Congress
would never be happy no matter what they
gave them this is a win and bar is a
cover-up Pro if that's what you want to
do bar is the guy you bring in I'm not
going to redo his cover-up credentials
again since I did them last week or the
week before but he is known for being
able to protect politicians in these
situations he's playing that role to a
tee and with every answer we should
trust him less and less and what's
interesting to see and I think I mean I
think this is a good thing we are
starting to see even some of the left
skeptics on Russia start to change their
tune to some degree so I'll give you one
example I mean the the right forget
about the right I'm not even we know
what the where the right is on this
issue but I'll give you one example um
one of the toughest critics of the
Russia probe from the left was the
intercepts Glenn Greenwald okay and
right after the four-page bar letter
came out Glenn Greenwald and I might do
a segment on this where I show you these
clips because it seems worth doing Glenn
Greenwald went on Democracy Now and I'm
sort of quoting from memory is simply
said there is no evidence no evidence of
wrongdoing against Donald Trump and he
was interviewed by Sam cedar on
yesterday's program and I talked to Sam
about about this last night and he is no
longer saying that there is no evidence
okay so what my hope is is that the left
the different sort of factions of the
left will unify behind one accurate
narrative on this and I believe that
that narrative has been clear from the
beginning that narrative is there is
evidence of significant wrongdoing by
Donald Trump and associates some of it
has to do with Russia
some of it has to do with financial
stuff some of it has to do with simply
trying to cover up the investigation
that took place it was never realistic
that Trump was going to be personally
caught colluding with Russia or Putin
it was never realistic to think that
charges were going to be brought against
Donald Trump for that obstruction was
the question let's really come together
here because I think it's important for
the left to be united on this and I'm
gonna be honest with you I don't think
the views on the left are actually that
different after seeing Sam talk to Glenn
Greenwald now that Greenwald has gotten
more of a sense of what we are likely to
expect from this report I think that the
difference is among the left are 90%
semantics tone and framing of the
importance of this issue and 10%
substantive I know that doesn't apply to
everybody there are people on the Left
who genuinely think there was no reason
to even start this investigation maybe
even that the investigation was carried
out incorrectly whatever but I truly
think that after these two weeks have
gone by where we see the political
nature of the bar letter and we have a
better understanding of what they are
attempting to do my sense is the left
most of the left is basically on the
same page although there are
disagreements in terms of how to discuss
this issue and hopefully in the next
couple of weeks the left will unite even
more because it's not good for the left
to be fractured on any issue at this
point in time and this is a big one and
we're heading into an important primary
an election that's my hope if I'm naive
wide-eyed and bushy tailed let me know
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show while you're there follow me on
Instagram at David Pakman I'll be
posting behind the scenes pictures from
what's going on here in Las Vegas the
progressive media meeting of the minds
in which I am participating we talk all
the time on the show about how big tech
and telecom corporations are invading
your privacy for-profit social media
platforms search engines internet
service providers they follow you around
on the internet collecting data about
your behavior selling your information
it should be concerning and I know that
it is to a lot of people in our audience
which is why I'm excited to tell you
about one of today's David Pakman show
sponsors Nord VPN which protects your
privacy online
by anonymizing your internet traffic
nord VPN is giving everybody in our
audience a 75% discount on a three-year
subscription this comes out to under
three bucks a month plus a whole month
free but you've got to go to Nord VPN
dot-com slash David Pakman and use the
coupon code david pakman all one word
when you use Nord VPN your IP address is
hidden websites can't follow you around
the internet it helps keep your
financial information safe from hackers
you can circumvent censorship
if websites are being blocked in certain
regions there's really no substitute for
making yourself anonymous online if you
want to take your privacy seriously I
use Nord VPN on all of my devices and I
just love having Nord VPN as a sponsor
because they're big supporters of
independent progressive media they
sponsor other progressive shows so
everyone in our audience should feel
great about being one of their customers
and like i mentioned david pakman show
viewers can get 75% off a three-year
plan of Nord VPN comes out to under
three bucks a month
plus a whole month free but you've got
to go to Nord VPN comm slash David
Pakman I've put the link underneath this
video then just use the coupon code
david pakman at checkout all one word